[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[болгарською]
Залишили красиві Балкани не для того,
щоб шукати кращого життя.
[болгарською]
А для того, щоб болгарами залишитись
і зберегти свій рід.
[Криничне,
Бессарабія]
Залишили красиві Балкани не для того,
щоб шукати кращого життя.
[Тетяна Станєва,
керівниця культурних проєктів
Центру розвитку Бессарабії]
А для того, щоб болгарами залишитись
і зберегти свій рід.
І власне, Криничне,
більше двохсот років
вони зберігають і мову,
і свою віру, релігію,
і свої традиції, і пісні.
І, на жаль, дуже багато відходить
разом із старими людьми
фольклору, пісень.
Але дуже багато ще є.
Діди робили вино,
батьки робили вино.
Ми теж дивилися.
В Криничному майже всі роблять вино.
Щороку у Болграді в цей час
проходить фестиваль.
Ми беремо участь з 2014 року.
Ну, нібито нагороди є,
та і вдається, загалом.
[Валерій Желясков,
винороб]
Запрошують нас, як не є.
Скільки кожен криничанець
має зробити тон вина?
Ми дійшли до такої цифри, що десь в середньому,
щоби пригостити,
щоби було...
Що віддати комусь,
подарувати і так далі...
Це в середньому
кожен має по тонні.
Від тонни до трьох.
Це десь три літри на день.
Для міських людей
це смішно,
але для наших людей...
Ну, до вина відносяться,
як до, напевно, до води.
Ну, тобто це...
Як це, якийсь газда
не буде мати води?
Я була, наприклад, такою
інноваторкою в цьому сенсі,
коли приїжджали якісь гості,
і я їх пригощала кавою.
Ну, пропонувала спершу каву і чай.
У нас ніхто не пропонує
каву і чай.
У нас всі пропонують вино.
Ні, ні, ні.
Таня, йдіть до нас грати в карти!
Ні ні ні, ми не будемо.
Ви можете їх прибрати.
Ми їх приберемо.
Не треба, не треба.
Хай знають, що ми робимо.
Так?
Можете тост сказати?
Спробуємо.
Одного разу Димитрій Солунський,
як опинився на цьому нашому прекрасному озері Ялпуг.
Він випадково тут опинився, випадково.
І його човен почав тонути.
Він почав виходити з води, а тут на березі сиділи болгари.
Отак сиділи.
Каварма  на столі,
червоне вино п’ють.
Він здивувався.
Сказав: «Тут оселюсь.
Тут мені зробите храм».
І ось там на горі в нас зробили йому храм
на честь Димитрія Солунського.
Й п’ємо за храм. За Димитрія.
За здоров'я Димитрія!
Давайте, будьмо! Дай, Боже, здоров’я!
А хто з вас Дмитро?
Усі. Ми усі.
В цей день усі стають Дмитрами.
Усі — Дмитрами.
Ай, за здоров'я.
Дім — це не тільки вікно і двері.
Дім — це фамільне гніздо.
І тому вони дуже прив'язані до своїх хат.
Якщо ви помітили, у нас хати
дуже відрізняються від інших сіл.
Мабуть, немає в Україні
більше таких побудов.
Моя хата одна з таких класичних,
де немає абсолютно
жодної внутрішньої кімнати,
тобто всі йдуть одна за одною
і багато-багато входів.
Хтось їх навіть із приїжджих,
я десь бачила в інтернеті,
обізвав під'їздами.
Мені так було смішно.
Ми ніколи так це не називали.
Я зараз жартую з мамою, кажу:
«Я в другий під’їзд»
Ну, тобто це...
Для чого це робилося?
Тому що жили... В принципі,
за звичаєвим правом
У нас всі живуть з батьками.
Тобто діти доглядають батьків
і живуть, і народжують онуків.
Якщо там, наприклад, двоє сестер
за звичаєвим правом
у нас дім не ділиться на двох,
як за законом України.
У нас дім залишається
молодшій сестрі,
і вона доглядає за батьками.
Оце тільки хата,
яку вже потім зробили:
відокремили її.
А так, в принципі, все іде отак:
кімната за кімнатою
і вихід на вулицю.
Ой.
Тату, тебе зараз знімати будуть.
Ну ось так от воно іде,
і аж до самої кухні.
Таке планування —
стандартне для криничанців.
Тут уже кухня.
Село знаходиться на березі
найбільшого озера в Україні.
Багато хто не знає в Україні –
Це озеро Ялпуг.
Ось ці красоти, які ми бачимо,
це — захід сонця.
Кожного дня за озером.
Це не може не сформувати
смак у людей.
Наші люди відрізняються особливим смаком:
в одежі, в тому, як вони виглядають,
в убранстві хати.
І певно, от, сонце, природа
і отакі красоти — вони впливають.
[говорять болгарською]
Зі святом!
І вас зі святом!
Маш, підійди сюди.
Підійди до нас.
[Марія Желяскова,
виноробка]
Я зараз скажу.
Значить, за звичаєм, який є
у Криничному, тобто лише в Чушмелії.
Мабуть, із гордістю про це кажу, що
у жодному нашому
бессарабському болгарському селі
не прослідковується ця традиція, цей звичай.
Він є у нас.
І він настільки
плідно та добре
із Божою поміччю працює,
що люди часто
ним користуються.
Наш випадок:
коли так сталося,
що Саша захворів дуже надовго
і це тривало півроку...
І є старі люди, які...
От тітка моя, мама, сказали:
Його треба лиш...
Подарувати цю дитину.
У цьому світі йому
потрібна друга мама,
щоб вона могла
за нього молитися.
Так.
Болгарською мовою це називається «арізвань».
Я не знаю, як це перекласти.
Названа мати
в українській традиції.
— Названа мати або побратимство.
— Так, це «арізвань» перед Богом.
Тобто, данину Богові віддати.
От хто перший завтра зайде
в наш будинок,
відповідно до нашого звичаю,
той і буде названими батьками:
мамою або татом, хто там буде,
брат, сестра, дитина якась.
Може бути хто завгодно.
Було навіть таке, що
люди заходили попросити милостиню
і їм дарували дітей.
Тобто це може бути геть чужа людина.
Так сталося, що рано вранці
подзвонила моя сестра.
[говорять болгарською]
Це вино
[Болград,
Бессарабія]
Так багато людей у нас
на площі тут в Болграді
ще не бачила.
Мене це тішить особисто
дуже сильно тому, що
люди почали їздити.
Я бачила там намет із Закарпаття,
і вони варять бограч.
Це така...
Це свято певно таке
міжкультурне тому, що
як може бути інакше в Бессарабії?
У нас тут багато націй.
І гагаузів, і молдован,
і албанців я бачила.
Я вважаю, що в Україні немає ще одного такого місця,
де би можна було би
в такому яскравому вигляді
зробити гастротуризм.
Він тут просто...
Тут знайдеш все, що забажає душа.
Я дуже хочу підняти
туристичний потенціал
нашого краю
отакими фестивалями, фільмами,
де буде показано колорит.
Я думаю, ми це доб'ємо.
Ми зробимо Бессарабію меккою українського
туризму і не тільки.
По суті, зшити Європу з нами
і показати для місцевих, наскільки...
Ось Європа — через Дунай.
А ви дивитеся не в той бік взагалі.
Змінювалася влада.
Тут була і ...
Вони заселилися — ще була Російська імперія,
потім це була румунська влада,
потім це була радянська влада,
потім це знову була румунська
і потім радянська.
Зараз це — Україна.
І кожного разу перед ними стояло
одне й те саме питання:
Як вижити і як зберегти себе?
Власне, вони його вирішили.
Коли Україна стає незалежною,
я би назвала це
«золотий вік» болгар тут,
у Бессарабії.
Тому що починається таке відродження, відкриваються кордони,
стає доступною інформація, пісні.
Починають шукати місця, звідки ми пішли.
І ми знаходимо архіви,
ми починаємо спілкуватися
з тими людьми,
звідки ми виїхали з Болгарії.
Це дуже збагачує
і нас самих як болгар,
І я думаю, Україну і
національну мапу України в принципі.
[Перші болгари з'явилися на території України у XVIII-XIX ст.]
[Тікаючи від горінь турків, вони осідали на Бессарабії, Причорномор'ї та в Криму (Таврії)]
[Із приходом Радянського союзу частина переселилася з Бессарабії на Приазов'я]
[У 1944 році в рамках сталінського «очищення» Криму від представників інших етрічних груп]
[понад 12 тисяч болгар депортували з півострова]
[Частина українських болгар загинула внаслідок Голодомору 1946-47 років]
[Сьогодні в Україні понад 200 тисяч болгар.]
[Переважна більшість компактно мешкає в селах Бессарабії.]
[Це п'ята за чисельністю національна спільнота в країні.]
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Микола Носок]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Субтитрувальниця
Валерія Діденко,]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія створена за підтримки Агенства США з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]